President Trump is choosing not to
follow new federal guidelines that urge
Americans to wear face coverings in
public his decision comes as the
administration takes decisive action to
shore up the nation's devastated economy
the latest jobs report reveal the loss
of seven hundred and one thousand jobs
in the month of March with unemployment
taking up to 4.4 percent
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning a cold good morning good
morning to you Jeff President Trump says
he's not going to wear a mask since he's
tested negative for coronavirus and
assumes he isn't spreading the disease
even as the first lady suggested people
should take these guidelines seriously
so with the masks it's going to be
really a voluntary thing president
drumlin veiled new recommendations from
the Centers for Disease Control urging
Americans to our cloth or fabric face
masks in public but he made clear he
won't be following them sitting in the
Oval Office behind that beautiful
resolute desk the great resolute desk
I think wearing a face mask as I greet
presidents prime ministers dictators
kings queens I don't know somehow I
don't see it for myself the announcement
came as the president put pressure on
manufacturer 3m to make more protective
masks by invoking the defense production
act and used the same powers to ban
so-called profit ears from exporting
medical supplies out of the country the
president's son-in-law Jared Kushner has
been working with FEMA to help oversee
the supply chain from the strategic
national stockpile but he came under
scrutiny this week after seeming to
suggest it wasn't for States a
government website was later updated
with a similar description the notion of
the federal stock Powell wasn't supposed
to be our stockpile
[Music]
United States of America that's what it
means the president also addressed the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve in a meeting
with energy executives allowing them to
temporarily store surplus oil Friday the
administration also rolled out another
part of its economic relief package a
350 billion dollar loan program for
small businesses I know there's a lot of
hard-working small businesses that
couldn't get their applications
processed this week they shouldn't worry
about it there's plenty of time there's
plenty of money left the Small Business
Administration says it's already given
out thousands of loans worth over four
billion dollars the Trump administration
also announced it would reimburse
hospitals that treat the uninsured for
coronavirus Jeff cool thank you very
much